she like chicken they got too many veins
to me the Frog thing you see the frog
legs and you're like man that's a
[__] Lake nah yeah but it looked like
a chicken though see I if I know it's a
frog I ain't [__] with that right
what you know it's a chicken Society is
desensitized me it made me okay with
eating a chicken
like a frog could be my homie yeah I
mean I got a pet Frog as a kid yeah
oh really what I had a pet frog named
Fat Joe did you ever have a turtle
though yeah I had Turtle though I had a
turtle here the frog is lit and that's I
had a baby frog oh really so it's like
little yeah what did you feed it like
crickets and [__] I didn't feed anything
that's probably why I died man they
killed my dad my killing frog a day cut
ain't putting a hole in the top oh well
he probably died from starvation and
from nowhere worry about that from both
of them
night named Jimmy Jimmy the Frog yeah
see I see that's why I can't eat a frog
you can eat Jimmy can't you can't eat
Jimmy I don't have a pet [__] cow bro
I need a burger you know what I'm saying
yeah